Karies ist echt eine geißel der menschheit laut weltgesundheitsorganisation die hsk ist tatsächlich eine der größten gesundheitsgefahren
für die menschen in den industrieländern verursacht durch bakterien und befeuert durch zucker den wir täglich zu uns nehmen
Entstehen die löcher in den zähnen und jetzt sollen es tatsächlich möglich sein sich gegen karies impfen zu lassen
Wie der impfstoff funktioniert ob er eine allzweckwaffe gegen karies ist und ob jetzt endlich schluss mit dem lästigen
Zähneputzen ist jetzt in klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Streptococcus mutans
Alleine der name des bakteriums klingt fürchterlich und alle die schon einmal löcher in den zähnen hatten wissen dass dieser name
des karrees erregers völlig zu recht einen so
Angsteinflößenden klang hat die bakterien treiben nicht nur im mund von denjenigen unter uns sehr unwesen dies mit der zahnhygiene nicht
So genau nehmen auch menschen die zwei bis dreimal täglich zähne putzen dann noch
zahnseide benutzen und außerdem noch mundspülungen machen haben nicht selten mit karies
Zu kämpfen doch damit könnte jetzt schluss sein denn einem forschungsteam aus china ist jetzt wohl das gelungen was
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler schon seit rund 60 jahren
versuchen einen
impfstoff gegen die bakterien zu entwickeln in der vergangenheit konnte bereits schon einmal ein effektiver wirkstoff gefunden werden doch immer
zeigten sich ungewollte nebenwirkungen wie etwa entzündungen das chinesische forschungsteam
Knüpfte an frühere studien an in denen man versucht hat er verschiedene proteine zu verschmelzen ihr ziel dabei
streptococcus mutans
letztendlich daran gehindert werden an die zelle anzudocken und tatsächlich durch die kombination von verschiedenen
proteinen konnten die nebenwirkung laut der aktuellen chinesischen
Studie minimiert werden doch die wirkung wie behalten den tierversuchen bei denen der impfstoff mäusen und ratten über die nasen verabreicht wurde
verhinderte der entwickelte impfstoff in knapp
65 prozent der fälle ein carius ausbruch bei rund der hälfte der tiere
Die mit dem erreger infiziert waren konnten die erkrankung geheilt werden jetzt stehen erst einmal weitere tests an bevor der impfstoff wohl
millionen menschen auf der welt helfen könnte und zwar nicht nur menschen in industrieländern
die durch übermäßigen zuckerkonsum
carius bekommen haben sondern auch betroffenen in
entwicklungsländern denn dort haben die menschen teilweise keinen zugang zu frischem wasser
zahnbürsten und, zahnpasta
zudem fehlt oft das wissen bezüglich einer effektiven zahnhygiene doch alle die jetzt glauben dass dieser impfstoff
uns irgendein man einmal vom lästigen
zähneputzen befreien wird die muss ich enttäuschen das betont dass chinesische forschungsteam selbst der impfstoff ist lediglich als eine ergänzung zur täglichen
zahnpflege gedacht denn eines steht fest der
Streptococcus ist nicht der einzige übeltäter mund durch den um stoff wird er zwar gewinnt sich auf der oberfläche der zähne
festzusetzen dennoch kann er sich weiter
Im und ausbreiten den final besiegt wird er dich diesen impfstoff nicht
Da sage ich mal noch nicht wie die menschheit an den pocken gezeigt hat ist sie in der lage krankheiten
Vollkommen auszurotten nur bei den masern da hakt es
Im moment weil egoismus und dummheit flächendeckende impfungen verhindert aber da kommen wir wahrscheinlich durch impfpflicht dem ziel näher ich sehe da durchaus eine
verheißungsvolle zukunft sein werden der höchstwahrscheinlich immer mal wieder von großen auch tödlichen epidemie heimgesucht aber impfstoffe werden wohl immer schneller und effektiver
Gefunden werden ein riesen thema auf jeden fall jeweils um halte ich euch dazu
Natürlich auf dem laufenden wenn ihr kein video zum thema und auch zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann wird mir hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergesse nicht den
Genau auf die glocke hier geht es weiter mit super
Bazillus aufgetaucht fachleute befürchten pandemie da geht es um einen wirklich ziemlich tödlichen super bazillus der eine pandemie auslösen könnte gerade wurde er entdeckt
extrem spannendes video also nicht verpassen und draufklicken und ansonsten bis dann
bleib dran